this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday june 13th
the joint is brought to you by blue chew
listen if you're looking for some summer
loving make sure you got some blue chew
jack because the summer's coming up
[__] quickly and nobody wants to
sling that dick you understand me
blue chew is
it will help you with your erectile
dysfunction you can take it any day any
time day or night it's a simple process
you sign up at bluetooth.com
you talk to one of the licensed medical
providers once you're approved you'll
receive your prescriptions in days you
understand me no doctor's office no
pharmacy no judgment just time to sling
dick blue chew tablets are made in the
usa it ships right to your door in a
discrete package and nobody knows
nothing i'm not saying you got erectile
dysfunction what i'm saying is that you
want to be a little bit more confident
you want to walk in there with a big
dick and a smile with one of those
things around your head like the saints
have blue chew will help you get that
you understand me it's safe you can put
in your pocket take it at night day it
don't matter if you could benefit from
extra confidence or blue chew
this is it blue chew has a special deal
for the joint listeners you ready this
try blue chew free joey what do you talk
free
use my promo code joey at checkout just
pay 5 000 shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month for free you understand me blue
chew is tremendous i love it
i'm an old guy i got problems so i need
bluetooth but you guys are strong you
always want to have a [__] backup you
don't want to just show up with one gun
do you visit bluetooth.com for details
and important safety information we
sponsor we thank bluechu for sponsoring
the joint the joint is also brought to
you by
best spoke post shake up your summer
routine with best poke and their new box
of awesome collections listen they sent
me a knife a big [__] knife whiskey
glasses and a one hitter that's
tremendous
bespoke post partners with small
businesses to bring you the unique stuff
every month i like their scotch box with
the hot sauces from all over the country
take the quiz at box of awesome.com and
they'll help you pick out the right box
for you you only pay a fraction of what
these boxes are worth ninety percent of
everything
in the box is from a small up-and-coming
brand if you sign up you can skip a
month
and cancel anytime so do me a favor get
you get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at boxer office box of awesome
a-w-e-s-o-m
dot-com box of awesome
dot-com enter code joey and check out
again
that's box of awesome dot com
code joey j-o-e-wy
for 20 off your first box
now
let's get this party started it's monday
morning jack it's gonna be a great week
with uncle joey
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
yes it is it's monday the 13th
if you're looking for black cats you
gotta wait till friday
it's a beautiful [__] day to be alive
was a great [__] weekend for you guys
that downloaded the ant my heart goes
out to you i love you [__] i
got an email into them we'll probably
hear everything tomorrow i gotta give
you a password now
and then we'll get this [__]
party started one night of [__]
week
i'm excited and the other thing too guys
this amp
was just a suggestion from me
i don't know if you guys maybe it's time
for you [__] to blast off with
some [__] djing and talking [__] you
guys been listening to podcasts for what
20 [__] years now you guys are all a
bunch of [__] experts when you
download that app make yourself a little
[__] uh a show every [__] week you
know
johnny black's [__] rock station talk
some [__]
you know you never know guys maybe uh
doing a radio show is up your [__]
alley right you like music you like
talking [__] you like smoking dope you
like getting your dick sucked yeah
that's that's the [__] hey that's the
job description you know what i'm saying
you like eating ass you like working
with dirty women you like sucking dirty
toes do you like getting sexual [__]
diseases and rashes and [__] like that
that don't hit you right away to hit you
20 years later you know all that type of
[__]
if that's the [__] career choice you
want you never know it might be the
[__] way to go
ufc was great saturday night i didn't
watch the [__] thing until the next
day i just watched i gave a [__] about
joanna against uh
the chinese chick you know all week long
like mondays before a fight
i always open up the draftkings app and
i see what the lines are on monday right
and i just make little assumptions in my
brain i'm like if i bet twenty dollars
on glover how much will i win if i want
twenty dollars on this guy how much will
i win if i put 20 like valentina this
week if you bet 25 hours you sweat
through that whole fight pulled your
hair out for two dollars you made two
dollars for that whole [__] fight if
you had a parlay with glover i mean uh
with the other guy that won the new
champion and valentina if you bet ten
dollars you probably lost the [__]
dollar on those parlays you know and
that's just the way it is you got to bet
really heavy on those to make any
[__] money and who wants to bet 500
to win 125 that's bad business so you
just walk the [__] away from it so
last monday i opened up the app and
valenti like if you bet joanna
20 bucks you 160.
dawg this is the ufc you guys know
weirder things have happened you just
throw a punch up the chick gets hit and
that's it we call a [__] fight herb
dean loves to call early fight you know
so you bet the [__] thing but i
didn't bet monday i wanted to see where
it was going
and friday i wake up and again i go on
[__] draftkings the app and boom
[__] i'm still getting 60 bucks for
joanna this line has not moved
so i started calling people who know the
fight game a little more than i do
and they said that joanna hadn't fought
in a while uh her last two outings
weren't that good you know so i said you
know what she still was a champion
i love her [__] you know her style
her kicks the way she fights
i mean let's see what happens and then
i don't know last week it was
and i was watching tv with my wife i
forgot all about the [__] fights guys
when i look at those fights and i see
[__] you know
eighty dollars and i i really wanna
watch three fights and then i gotta stay
up till [__] midnight you know and
get my money's worth out of the fight
i got to be in the [__] mood it was
like telling mike you know friday night
i [__] went out
i went to uh a buddy's house around the
corner
and uh
i [__] got sick
seven
minutes away
so
hear me out i went to atlantic city and
back
i went to point pleasant three times and
i went to [__] east brunswick oh
whatever the [__] new brunswick one time
or two times never got [__] sick
didn't even think about it and did the
18 which the 18 is a [__] right-hand
[__] you make a right on the elect on
that on the 18 any [__] right on the
18th south or the 18th north and it's
like a [__] mile loop you're like
holding on to your [__] car like
shaking like when the [__] is this loop
gonna end but those loop-de-loops
[__] kill me i used to love them with
the hot wheels you've had the
loop-de-loop and [__]
i don't know what the [__] happened to
the looply loop but
that loop-de-loop on the 18 every time i
[__] get off that's like the final
[__]
stab in jesus on [__] sunday when
they stab him in the heart because i'm
already a little [__] up
so i got guys i went so all these
distances are 20 minutes 25 minutes
i went seven minutes
seven minutes on friday did not take an
edible
did not drink a cocktail and believe it
or not this guy doesn't smoke pot so i
don't like that he's got kids so i
wouldn't even want to go over there
smelling like jerry garcia so i want to
you know i did like a hit early in the
night or whatever
i go over there we're watching the
[__] celtic game friday night the
celtic game ends no big deal i think i
drank a water and i ate you know two
little pieces of popcorn i [__] hate
popcorn so i just that's all he had on
the counter so i watched the game i went
home it had to be uh
11 40.
guys [__] first turn i'm starting to
[__] i'm like nah
this is probably [__] leftover edible
juice
that's just getting me a little fired up
making a comeback at night
[__] no dawg and it's seven minutes by
the fifth minute i was already puking
out the [__] window
and then i [__] puked again and i
puked in my driveway then i puked in the
toilet then i went to sleep and i woke
up at three and i drank half a bottle of
pepto-bismol which i don't [__] know
who makes that
but that [__] tastes like ass and it
just sits in your stomach it works i'm
not
i'm not mad at anybody it [__] works
to death
but uh it just does not taste good and
then saturday i was robots all day
had a few games up in old bridge
you know my daughter played the [__]
listen man
it's great to see the growth in children
it's great to see the growth of anybody
it's great when you
last year i give an example last year
there was a girl who came up no
athleticism whatsoever built like a
michelob bottle
she was in no danger we were running the
bases she was so out of shape
there was days where she would just sit
in the outfield then you gotta love her
she's a great kid you know she didn't
play on our team but i watched it
there's like [__] six marble teams
right so
i'm watching her and i i don't know
i don't talk to her parents or anything
she's just a sweet girl she talks to my
daughter
and then
in the offseason you know the girl did
so bad last year that
i didn't think she was going to come
back like i didn't think she was going
to come back and i had you know whatever
kids are kids
but she came back
and mercy played in the league up than
her so she's nine but she plays in the
lower nine
and at one of the games i saw her dad or
something you know nice guy he's like
yeah you know she feels bad she i go
listen
listen let me tell you what happens she
came another year
she [__] showed up for another year
so obviously she [__] likes it right
i go
this is going to catch them up trust me
what i'm telling you this is going to
catch them up because
maybe my daughter inspire her or she'll
inspire my daughter and that's the way
everybody works
let me tell you something that girl
[__] won a a game yesterday she
pitched the game the girl that was
athletically in no danger last year that
she would sit in the outfield
and chase [__] flowers and [__] like
that and get stung by bees
well yesterday she struck out like five
five [__] people and she won on
saturday whatever the [__]
so when you hear this you're like god
damn that's great now i watch
them practice the girls you know my
daughter's team my wife you know i'm
there i talk to the dads i i bring a
little vapor pen i get a little [__]
tootsie roots and i go and i talk to the
parents i bring a [__] water and you
sit out there and get vitamin d and i
gotta tell you man
i showed up this year one time like i
went to get something for the girls or
something when i came back i'm like
where the [__] is my daughter i got on
the bench
and i'm sitting there i'm like who the
[__] is this little catcher
this little catch is like throwing her
fingers up two hours
and after a couple minutes ago
that's my daughter i could not [__]
believe she was catching
and i'm like holy [__]
and now the two girls that were
non-existent on her team like
yesterday uh saturday some girl won the
mvp on both games he was quiet all
season
guys it goes back to what we [__]
explored on the church
just keep showing up just keep showing
up
i got my third stripe at jiu jitsu
sunday i am [__] horrible in jiu
jitsu do you understand me i am horrible
but you know what they have a thing for
the class and i told the guy go guy my
knees hurt i haven't even come to the
bulldog class how can you give me a
stripe and he goes dawg
you keep coming
even though your knee is hurt
you keep showing up and you do the
exercises and you run and you do the hip
escapes and i could see that you're
learning i could see your cardio is
getting better i was a little
embarrassed when he goes i'm giving out
stripes today i'm like i mean i ain't
got no [__] strike and also i got a
[__] strike you know what guys
i kept showing up i'm not a jiu jitsu
master
i'm never gonna be a jiu jitsu master it
doesn't give a [__]
i go there i burn three 400 calories i
take a shower i eat something i get the
[__] thc juice and whatever other
juice i got in my body sweat out
and i'm a happier person over it again
i'm not the f at all i'm not even dog if
i was uh if you ranked me as a comic for
a jiu jitsu i wouldn't even be an emcee
i'm like an open mica
but i go there today i rolled you know
you roll you get beat up you tap and
that's it you move the [__] on and
but one of my options to sit here and
get bigger and fatter
and at least move around right now i
lift twice and i go to two to three jiu
jitsu's and
it's working i gotta wear a [__] knee
brace with [__] metal bars in it i
feel like one of those [__] [__] up
kids but this is what it is and it lets
me [__] get better and it lets me get
stronger
you know i've been uh
i've been [__]
liquid iv [__] suckers oh my god these
are great especially after you're
sweating [__]
if you're just gonna drink it to sit at
home you're just gonna get fat as [__]
because it's got tons of sodium
and you're just gonna [__] get all
juicy and [__] but if you're really
[__] sweating and that stuff is
coming out of you this liquid iv is
tremendous the concord grape i can't get
away from it it's like i remember years
ago when i went to the longest yard guys
i walked on that [__] set and i was
busting the seam at 390.
the first week which nobody [__]
knows about all right i never really
discuss you don't discuss when you
[__] you know
i just humiliated you i'm saying like
you just humiliated so
i check into my hotel room that monday
whatever we have the table read the next
day they go joe you're not working all
week
but they're doing a conditioning
football thing just so you go out there
and get familiarized the positions and
[__]
i go what time is it there i go it's
going to be 10. i'll be that quarter to
10. you know me i'm ready to [__]
rock
guys i show up
i haven't done an exercise at this point
beside walking on stage
for 10 years there was no lifting
weights there was nothing i lived across
the street from hawaii
there was nothing i just
got on that [__] thing
and the football coach goes joey you're
playing the defensive tackle so you
stand here and i knew it i knew where to
stand i knew all the the positions and
[__]
i think they said joe we're just going
to do one shot from the side to see how
you block and all this stuff
and i went to block this guy he just
took my arm and threw me on the [__]
floor i was like yeah and when i fell
down i didn't even fall i bounced
there's a big difference between falling
and bouncing
you you ever see those big balls at the
gym
those big round balls that you lay on
and [__] could you imagine that they had
arms and legs and you just threw it and
how it bouncing bone
that was me dog i bounced and i couldn't
even [__] bounce again like i just
rolled on this part of my body i was
just stuck in that position
like he's like joey are you okay i'm
like i don't [__] think so so he
grabbed me and he goes this is what
we're gonna do we're just gonna walk the
sides with an oxygen tube in your nose
so here's all these dudes
you know he is [__] the dalips and
the [__] you know the
just these guys that are in [__]
magnificent shape
and his fat slob uncle joey on the
sideline with oxygen [__] things just
walking back and forth and they gave me
like a two pound weight and they go just
start there joey and i'll never forget
goldberg
god bless his soul he's like that dude
is dying
look at his face this is not right my
[__] face was beat red and it's
elevated like it's uh oxygen
he's like this dude's dying he ain't
dying on my watch he goes come here kid
and he [__] wanted his bag and he
took out a grape
the [__] you give to kids
no i've done the [__] that when the
kid's sick you give them to him like you
know you got kids at home they're great
but
no it's like gatorade for kids
it's like grape and cherry and fruit
punch and it comes in
big gallon [__] containers dog i was
dying it was hot i couldn't breathe
he gave me that [__] thing and it was
and um there was an ic it was like uh
it's a kid's drink you guys know what
the [__] it is it's it's uh
no it's it's a it's a vitamin drink for
babies if they get hydrated if your baby
gets sick
pedialyte you get the grape [__] and
i'll never forget i drank that grape
[__] i'm like this is [__] good
so he goes listen i got tons of this
[__] they they send it to me about a
gallon this is what i drink when i lift
weights i'm like dog i'm hanging out
with you all [__] week so all week
that first week all i had to do
was go to the sidelines report
you know i tried to do jumping jacks i
tried to do squats and [__] i was doing
the squats the push-ups it was harder
for me to get up than the [__]
push-up by the time i got down and got
in the push-up position is 20 [__]
minutes i was so big
so that was all week i was run to that
thing because i loved those great
[__] pedia lights
walking back and forth with my little
five pound
kettlebell and [__] and
pushing an oxygen [__] thing can you
imagine this you know i don't know if i
ever told you this i i tell these
stories like when lee was around because
lee would go no that never happened to
you yes and [__] deadly
yes it [__] did i realized
you know the worst thing in life is to
go somewhere like when i go to jiu jitsu
now i'm bearable like i could do the
warm-up and that for me like listen i
remember alberto crane once said
if a person over 50 comes to my jiu
jitsu class and they just do the warm-up
i'd be really happy with them
and they started from there if they
could just do the warm-up i could do the
[__] warm-up at least and i could do
the hip escapes i can't do the [__]
somersaults i'm not even going to try
those [__] things like landing on
your shirt your shoulder and going over
if you get me a normal plot and it hurts
i'll flip but until then i ain't gonna
flip all right i ain't gonna happen
but on in that movie man that's the
worst when you get thrown into something
and you
you're not prepared
like right before i went to prison i
[__] started swimming in the masters
program in boulder
some guy came in a ups guy he was yoked
and i just asked him i said dog i keep
lifting weights i'm getting big but i
want to start
ripping some of this fatness off some of
his muscle off me when i go to prison
and i thought he was going to go yeah
come meet me like a two and this
motherfucker's like show up at 6 00 a.m
and you could swim with me and i'm like
what and you know those situations where
you're like i already opened my [__]
fat mouth now i gotta go down there
[__] six in the morning you know
because i'm not the guy comes to my job
every day he's gonna embarrass me in
front of everybody where the [__] were
you
so i went there at six in the morning
dog i didn't know what to expect did i
feel like getting on a bike and leaving
[__] yeah
the first time the league goes get in
the pool i got in the [__] pool she
goes just swim for me so i can see you i
must have been in there like 10 minutes
just thinking i was mark spitz
water was going everywhere i'm trying to
do a [__] puerto rican whatever the
[__] what do you call that when you're
the the that one the whatever the [__]
the breast no this is the breaststroke
but then they have the one that they
they're doing the olympics and [__] yeah
i was in no danger i'm almost drowning
with the [__] buoy
and she came in and she taught me how to
swim properly that's [__] up when you
think you know how to swim
and
you can [__] drown like that day i
kiss on the way out i go man
i was 25 years old i thought i could
[__] swim
i jumped in the pool they were looking
at me like a black dude because black
dudes from a certain age i just read
this the other day black dudes like
60 percent of black dudes can't [__]
swim i don't understand that [__] but
i'm not it's not racist or not i'm just
saying that
i don't understand how the [__] they get
on 60 they do everything else they slam
basketball they hit home runs they play
gulp and you can't [__] swim yeah but
i saw that movie about the black
swimmers a couple years ago there was a
movie anyway who gives a [__] my point
is
i tried to get in the pool and i didn't
know how to [__] swim and it was
humiliating
it was [__] humiliating nothing worse
than getting into something and just
like being [__] completely out of it
like when mike brought me the guitar i i
didn't even know where to start i ain't
no better now
but at least now i can play cocaine i
can spit out a couple [__] you know
it sounds like a [__] up angus got his
finger cut off but it's ac dc you know
what i'm saying but when you don't have
any like my daughter never played
baseball before
and let's impress the [__] out of me in
two years she's made the all-star she's
doing this hey whatever that [__]
kids but still she caught on to
something
and it just brings me back to [__] uh
just showing up not even worrying about
i don't care about belts i don't care
about anything when you're doing comedy
i learned that from doing comedy man
that you could sit there for 10 years
and talk about the sound that they see i
didn't like it
you know the lights on raspberry park
listen stop [__] complaining
because you're gonna have to do this for
10 years
so if every room you go to you're going
to come up with a [__] i don't like
that room because [__]
they have listen guys there's going to
be something so just put your head down
and keep [__] going i tell you
for a long time we discussed on this
podcast about me going to do stand-up
for months
for months guys i looked at that clock
at 7 30 and i'm like
i'm smoking some pot i ain't getting a
[__] car and doing stand-up but then
something happened
i went down there with tom
and again it took me two weeks to go up
then i went down there with brian cowan
then again it took me two weeks then i
went down
to east uh to
whatever on my own one night
and that felt okay then i took two weeks
and then i said [__] it
i'm gonna get on stage once a week i
just don't know when i'm just gonna pick
a night when we're free and my daughter
doesn't have a game or not and you know
what that was three weeks ago
so in three weeks
i've gotten on stage three times four
four weeks in a row
i've gotten on stage
one thursday the thursday before rogan
and last thursday
so i got on stage three thursdays in a
row on the way home
you know i told him i said i'll be down
here every thursday
at uh uncle vinnie see don't go down
there do 15 10 minutes so let's pretend
i did all those [__] sets and even
the ones last year at vinnie's
guys it didn't come together till
thursday night
now i'm ready it was the weirdest
[__] thing
because the first night in atlantic city
i was stiff as a [__] board
saturday i loosened up a little bit the
material wasn't much better but i
loosened up a little bit i did a patreon
podcast last week and i discussed
did you ever see the sketches of marlon
brando getting goofed on when he did the
godfather that he didn't know his lines
okay
i saw that sketch a thousand times i
think
i think uh
marlon brenda was on saturday night live
and he [__]
with matthew broderick and matthew
brothers did a joke about him
putting stickers all over okay then i
think when they did when he did the grad
uh
he did a movie with matthew broderick
around i don't know 15 years ago
something about
he went to work for him on this in
little italy
and so saturday live blew it up and they
called back the sketch
the sketch was that in the godfather and
you could see pictures if you go online
and actually great [__] pictures
of uh marlon brando reading lines you
know rehearsing with mike me rehearsing
with mike
but what you're not seeing is mike's got
stickums on them
you know marlon brando will put stickums
on him
to remember his lines you know he put a
key words or something
and then they also have the [__]
pictures of marlin like with uh an easel
like whatever like whatever the [__] you
call holding
a big board like a you see at games you
suck all those boards with big boys with
the lions you know and people were
goofing on them he [__] [__]
won the academy award for the godfather
and people were goofing them that he
didn't know his [__] lines but
something that didn't get released that
i think you could find online it's
called acting class with marlon brando
he did it he did these things he did
these uh episodes i think he did like
ten episodes do not quote me on this he
could have done eight he could have done
six
but he did taught an acting class
and it was gonna run on like nbc or
something
but he died so they can the whole
project but they had those acting
classes he did six or eight classes or
whatever
i had a friend that was a comedian
and he was a promoter great guy out of
houston texas
this guy would send me
for about three or four years in a row i
lived off his deposits
because he would send me a gig he would
say hey man are you available november
8th i go yeah
he called me like november 1st hey man
the gig got pushed back
i'll call you when the new date comes up
they call you six months later and go
hey you available yeah
i'm gonna send you a deposit for 500.
they would cancel
this happened [__]
five times at this guy great guy and
then i just felt bad i'm like dude i
can't keep taking your nickels once i
stop snorting coke i'm like i can't take
your nickels no more because you just
give me money but anyway this guy was a
good guy and he was an actor he was a
great guy out of houston
and he sent me the clip one day because
i'm gonna send you a clip i i got in the
episode he was like one of the students
and he was
sent me the clip and this is really
[__] interesting
it was marlon brando saying listen man i
love these [__] [__]
that think they know acting you know and
all this [__]
just let them put to this way because
you know when i did that
sat you know when i did the godfather
did the signing
they did the sign i had live sketches
to try to [__] make me feel like a
mutt right he goes let me tell you the
truth about that
he goes
if you don't know your character
you're never gonna know your lines
what
he just kept saying if you don't know
your character you're never going to
lower your lines
and the whole class is like what the
[__] are you talking you know like
you know he said it he goes listen
if you don't know who that person is
deep down inside and you could see his
vision
the lines aren't gonna stick to you the
lines aren't gonna they're not gonna
work for you and that's why whenever i
get an audition
i always let's say they send you an
audition for frankie and on the bottom
of frankie
it says italian guy from the
neighborhood bookmaker
i don't know whatever [__] uh mobster
whatever i'll take that
breakdown when i agree to it and i'll go
i'll give frankie a last name
so i'll give frankie klein
half jewish half a talent i'm just
writing a story about that i don't even
know who this [__] guy is
i really don't but i just write so every
time i get an audition whatever the
guy's name is i get my last name
and i give him a [__] background why
i have no [__] idea that's how i was
taught to act
give that guy a background married kids
got left back from the second grade he's
missing the toe
whatever i don't get got vd whatever the
[__] you want to put cuz it doesn't
matter
it's somebody else's story but you're
lining this character down to the t his
mother's jewish his father's italian he
went the [__] and he took
latin in school i don't give a [__]
because the more
backstory you give to this guy the more
you'll know this guy so when you say
those lines that they give you you're
gonna remember him a lot easier trust me
you're talking to johnny i can't
remember a [__] joke when i go on
stage
but if you know the central part of this
[__] character
once you start reading the lines you're
gonna
absorb the lines a lot easier than if
you didn't know the [__] character so
for the last year and a half i've been
going up there and trying to tell jokes
and that's great joey that's what you
are a comedian and that's great but
guess what
everybody got jokes
everybody's got jokes
so you have to do
something more
you have to give them something more so
they can remember you right how do you
determine whether or not you like andrew
schultz
compared to big j orchestra they're
jokes
something they wear
something about their past something
about their life that's how you make
your connection okay
with me
i'm not a good writer guys
but i know that
you know i'm not john mullaney i'm not
david tell these guys a phenomenal
writer
tom segura is a very good writer uh
i could write 90 jokes
and not make you [__] laugh and
you'll go joey those are jokes from uh
you know judy carter stand up comedy
what the [__]
because it's everything else that comes
with it it's the whiff of your character
when i go on stage yeah my name is jose
diaz it's joey diaz but when i go on
stage the character's name is coco i'm
not responsible for what coco says
i don't even know what the [__] he's
gonna say that's not you know when you
see andrew dice clay is his real name is
max silverstein or whatever the [__] it
is
but on stage it becomes dice i've never
looked at it like this honest to god in
my 30 years of doing comedy but in this
situation
with me being away
from the stage so long for me being away
from writing so long and just doing a
podcast i got confused
so when i went on stage friday night i
knew something was missing i was around
joe if somebody was going to take it out
of me it was going to be jail with us
talking friday night when i went up
there on saturday i did different
materials some jokes were the same
but i did a lot better on saturday
because the character came out i paced a
little bit which is uncharacteristic for
me i paced from left to right which i
never do i never do that was the
replacement for the character the
character was trying to come out he just
didn't know what the [__] to do so he
walked back and forth like a dummy that
i am and i didn't feel it on the drive
home i was thinking how can i improve on
my set and where'd that pacing come from
because i have not paced on [__]
stage in 20 goddamn years i have not
paced on stage in seattle and that was
1997.
so whatever the [__] that is so i have
not paced i usually i like to do stand
up straight with the microphone there to
sell the joke with my hands that's the
movement of your hands to sell that
[__] joke and then movements on your
body the cap to put a period at the end
of that [__] sentence and to begin a
new one like i told you on the church
for rodney it was touching his
microphone it was touching his
microphone touching his his necktie he
gave you permission to laugh
they suck you in you know i always this
week i watched it again
if you're a stand-up or you want to
learn about stand-up before you watch
any of these netflix [__] special do
yourself a favor
watch rodney uh
specials with dice and i say this
repeatedly because people will not
listen
watch the andrew dice clay set from
danger fields
immediately rodney goes up does not do
any fluff
and goes on stage and brings up bill
hicks
watch dice's set
grab a pen
grab a piece of paper get a water sit
there and watch dice is set
he's saying jokes it's his character
he's [__] destroying i [__] love
it
he destroys so hard bill hicks comes up
and bill hicks is a pro
so if he young
somebody who's unprofessional somebody
who's
i shouldn't say unprofessional
somebody who's inexperienced if my man
wasn't experienced as he was bill hicks
he would have [__] to bed because he he
rushed it
like
15 years ago i would have gone on stage
after joe rogan
or dave chappelle or any of bill burr
any of those power houses
and even though i had skills i'd still
go up there and rush it
i try to get the taste especially if the
mc
doesn't do time in between them and
between me and somebody else
when r dice destroyed the room rodney
walks [__] up
and he goes let's keep it going for
andrew and he goes now coming to the
stage from houston texas this guy is so
[__] he's way ahead of his time bill
hicks there was no material there was no
chance to take the taste out of their
mouth there was nothing they had dice in
them dice hadn't come in their mouth
dice had come in their mouth in some way
figured out how to split his dick like
an amazon stock did you buy amazon stock
last week they're selling split stocks
and they [__] he put
two i mean dice destroyed the [__]
room
but when you see hicks come out hicks
comes out and you see the experience
he takes his time
plays with his [__] cigarette
because he knows he has you
he just he's luring you into a trap he's
like a [__] spider
trying to get a fly remember when i used
to capture flies it was like me i'm
going to start capturing flies again i
can't find one i got a jar the other day
but i could pop the top so i'm back jack
i forgot i used to give him [__] and
feed him and bring him up
i got to get my fly for him cooking
again anyway
uh when he [__] i watched it again
this week i've been watching it on
youtube as much as i can at night when i
write comedy now
i [__] put youtube on those specials
and i but i'm going back to the deep
ones
the rodney ones i found the bill hicks
special and i'm listening to these guys
but we're talking about hicks following
dice guys it's an education
and it's
it's like watching very good jiu jitsu
he puts his hands everywhere he's
technical and it's a [__] joy to
watch so
my point is i don't even know how you
got the [__] bill hicks and whatever
i got to stop smoking dope in the
morning
my point is that i'm back to the notion
where like after i drove home after the
third time i went on thursday
i was so proud of myself
just because i went out for two reasons
it had been the third week in a row
and it was the best that i [__] did
by far
last thursday at uncle vinnie's my set
was [__] awesome
and for me to say that what do i tell
you all this sense
something was missing
they laughed i could dawg i can make you
laugh but
that's not it i want to give you
something more if that character is not
in i'm missing it's and i have not come
back here at all not one time guys i
said i killed i leveled the room they
were holding onto their ears you know
they were puking that's a lie i that did
not happen i i appreciate you guys
that went to atlantic city and said i
killed and all this [__] listen i
appreciate you [__] and you
were happy to see me and honest to god
i was happy to see you [__] but
i didn't kill
last thursday i killed let me tell you
what how i know
none of that [__] i had in these
notebooks that i go up there and tell
none of those boring ass [__] jokes i
went up there and i told what was in my
stomach i could feel it coming out of my
stomach
like that puke on [__] friday night i
could feel it you know like when you're
gonna puke and you feel it and right
here you do that little burp that little
beaut
burp puke boot and then you have to
catch it with your own saliva and either
you swallow it or it [__] goes out if
you swallow it you're gonna [__] die
but guys i went up there and it was like
the first joke
was what i was thinking about but it was
not a joke guys
it was not even close
to being a [__] joke and i took off
with it by the
thank god
i taped the [__] set
by mistake i just said maybe i should
tape this set tonight and sure enough
guys when i got in the car that night to
drive home a little tear came down my
face
because it took me
[__] close to two years
to find myself that is
[__] crazy to find myself on stage
and like i thought guys i could go on
stage every night charge you 30 bucks
and take your money and half years of
leave that going that was great joey was
funny
but i'm gonna know i wasn't [__]
funny and i'm gonna know i wasn't great
and that's what was missing the [__]
the you know and it's like ari said to
me a couple weeks ago just come up and
tell a story he goes joey once you start
telling the story
he goes like you told any other story
you're going to get into it and you're
going to [__]
then everything comes in and it took
jesus christ 20 months you know i did
all those shows last year when i moved
here probably from november to february
i did probably 16 shows guys i could
tell you i didn't have one good show
not one good show
i think about him now i look all my
notes because when i get on stage i
always write the show and the note
all those shows i looked at him like two
weeks ago i was not happy
with not one of those shows uncle vinnie
i was doing old material it was
[__] coming up clunky i wasn't coming
up right
i was stuttering i couldn't remember
olive garden i couldn't remember jersey
mike's i couldn't remember basic [__]
things i couldn't listen
you remember your jokes but
you don't really want to say him after a
while once the pandemic came i wasn't
going to write those jokes down and
remember them and i tried them and i
i was connected to two jokes i really
liked but then i looked at me
and i'm like should i even be talking
about this [__] at this age what the
[__] is wrong with me
so now guys i just want to let you know
it's official i'm back
i feel good i'll be out this week i
don't know uh what shows you know
everything changes like last week i was
going on i was gonna go down to philly
bring duncan some [__] laughing gas
and hang out with duncan you know just i
haven't seen duncan [__] since a
pandemic i couldn't go down friday and
saturday i want to go down thursday and
see him and i could get home early was
just it's just an hour and seven minutes
with the [__] wave
it's away from south street i won't get
shot in philly but i love philly anyway
they ain't gonna shoot me down there
so
it started raining and all this [__] and
george couldn't drive so i said
[__] it i just go down to uncle uh
vinnie's you know so
then on the weekend i wanted to go see
jim norton on friday i heard he had
[__] great shows and uncle vinnie's
friday night my daughter had a game we
didn't get out of that till nine o'clock
went the [__] jersey freeze for the
first time
ah the burger was okay i didn't like the
bread it was on
the i didn't like i saw people eating
hot dogs they put [__] that jelly
that cheese sauce on it
i'm not uncle joey's not into cheese
sauce if you're gonna make a [__]
chili dog put some american cheese on
that [__] you know what if the
chili's really good i even take a piece
of cheddar on that [__]
yeah i don't like the cheese whiz guys
or cheese like that or not i don't like
cheese sauce okay i want [__] cheese
i don't want no cheese
sauce so yeah i don't like velvee it was
cousins to velveeta the burger was good
and i know the ice cream was really good
at jersey freeze i didn't have none
two i didn't want ice cream and three
the [__] line was on friday night
holy [__] they don't [__] around
you know we had a softball game and
freehold on the way home i said let me
let's just stop there we had the girls
we had like six [__] girls they were
happy they were jumping up and down
i said my wife got the cheesesteak it
didn't look bad again i was on the move
for a big [__] cheesesteak so i just
went with the cheeseburger not bad i
really wanted a [__] hot dog i've
been craving a hot dog my friend gave me
a jj's shirt hot dogs jj's hot dogs in
newark he brought me a chili dog one
time oh my god but he just brought me
one i'm like i appreciate the one guy
but
[__] one chili dog
it was tremendous you know but who the
[__] has time to go to newark to get a
[__] chili dog that's when you're a
real fat [__] if i gotta go to newark to
get a [__] chili dog i could just buy
two cigarettes get some [__] hostess
buns
[__] gets because you don't need like
great chili you just need like okay
chili like
and put a little [__] uh golden's
mustard on that [__] good googly
moogly
oh i'm getting [__] starving i'm
thinking about the [__] pickled
herring today jesus christ
i've been thinking about that they make
a cheeseburger at the pickled herring i
don't know what those jews put in it
i [__] love the pickled herring but i
went in there one day with florentine to
eat
and there were some people next to me
and florentine got like a pastrami
sandwich but there were some people
noticing me eating a cheeseburger i'm
like [__] that cheeseburger looks good
so i went in there to get some sandwich
oh when i went in there with lee to send
his mama
a [__] cat package
i went in there
and i asked the guy you guys make
cheeseburgers
lady goes listen they're [__] good
we make them in-house we pack them
in-house
so one sunday night we weren't doing
nothing let's get some i went over and i
got three cheeseburgers for me and terry
oh my god
so now
it's not bad enough they got good
pastrami forget about the corned beef
[__] sandwich
do what they call that corned beef with
the reuben
dog you got a corned beef reuben at the
pickled herring your [__] will be so
[__] happy
because the corned beef comes out
layered and that
fluffy [__] sauerkraut you blow farts
that makes you so happy you got an
elevator with a bunch of old people they
all got mask on you're like that ain't
stopping the odor that's about to come
out of my ass go you better triple mask
remember when these [__] are
triple masking oh
you eat a reuben from the [__]
pickled herring
you eat half of it it's got muts on it's
got the cheese melted they give you
crinkle cut fries
all the russian dressing i'm telling you
the pickled harry ain't [__] around
today now all i can think about is
yarmulke is your [__] and the cougar the
kruger is good in there
the [__] chicken soup is good the
matzo ball soup is getting i don't know
what it is with jews and chickens they
got a roasted chicken they're making
that good googly moogly sorry about this
guys
i'm getting you off from there how the
[__] did you bust out those amish donuts
you had poor lee
looking up amish people in florida
people go to florida look for cubans in
a [__] brazilian girlfriends lee goes
down there and looks he's looking up i
looked up amish to see where they were
and they have two restaurants who the
[__]
goes to i don't even know what the amish
eat but whatever
i guess it's [__] good but my point
is guys with the stand up
little commitments
become big commitments
some that i've been talking about for
years everybody goes wow
i don't want to go to the gym because
listen
just sign up
all these [__] gyms around here
jersey muscle
crunch all these [__] gyms around
here they want like five bucks
and like 10 bucks to go to classes
those are cheap things you're saying to
yourself joe i'm not healthy i get
emails every week from people joey i'm
out of weight i'm out of shape
i don't know where to start guys the
only [__] person you're fighting is
yourself the only war you're entangled
in is yourself everybody is pulling for
you at a gym everybody when you go to
the doctor's office where you think
they're going i hope his [__] leg
don't heal well i hope his eye don't
come back you know
everybody's healing uh cheering for you
when i go to jiu jitsu people are
cheering for you when you're gonna do
comedy
people are cheering for you it doesn't
matter you don't have to be the [__]
light the world on fire if you start by
going to the gym once a week
and you say to me in three months joey
i've been going to the gym for three
months but i just go once a week brother
that's a start
but you have not missed those [__]
three months not once you've made it
there and you stayed there for the
that's it now is when things are going
to start happening if you can you know
for me listen there's two types of
comics
no offense to anybody i'm not
trying to be a dick uh dick wad here
you know i love bill maher i watch his
show i like what he talks about
you know i love bill mark i like him as
a stand-up i like i watch his last
special
you know i've never seen
bill maher live maybe except three or
four times at the improv i've never seen
my other brother that i [__] love the
english guy that insults everybody they
were mad at him on netflix two weeks ago
i forget his [__]
ricky gervais i've never seen him work
out live i know he does like opiate
anthony with rich voss and those guys i
love to meet him you know i'm a fan of
his
uh george lopez when i was there gabriel
you know
gabriel's a [__] mega star he's over
in europe
selling everything the [__] out the
people from [__]
ukraine are even showing to his [__]
shows they're like [__] it we're going
my point is that gabriel those guys
never really worked out on stage like
when i became friends with gabriel i'd
see gabriel all the [__] time i mean
we were we did gigs together went to
chicago together with the [__]
modesto together but once gabriel hit
gaber was the type of guy that worked so
hard on the weekends he didn't really
work out during the week
you know vass is an international
[__] superstar i can't see him going
to the stand
eight nights a week or the comedy seller
and getting mobbed by people and getting
tortured you know
there's a couple different types of
comics there's comics that i wish i was
one of those comics because i tried it
i'm not gonna lie to you you know i wish
i was a comic that was writing based
that i just had to write my jokes put
them in order and then when i'm ready
maybe one do one warm up one night
and then when i'm ready for the big show
do the warm-up i wish i could do that
carlin i don't really know how he worked
i never i only saw him one time in
spokane doing like a show
but
that doesn't work for me like i got to
be loose like i got to be really [__]
loose
and that tightness i had the last 20
months from the pandemic whatever it was
affecting my stand up it wasn't going to
work it wasn't i let myself go and i let
coco take over but guys it's it's
going back to what i said it all starts
with one thing a week
i'm not sweating at all my mood has been
better
you know i wish i'd go out every night
with mike and do the open mics and
giggle but mike's got kids
i got kids i got responsibilities i'm an
old man sometimes my ass hurts something
every day is a new [__] adventure in
this [__] house
you know like i told you i twist the
right ankle i wake up thursday the left
ankle [__] hurts
but it's little commitments become big
commitments if you
do anything this monday to make yourself
better
this week upcoming week i know you're
slug you know maybe you're
you're struggling with
listen i don't care even with coke like
i could tell you guys that yeah one day
i just woke up and i miraculous didn't
look up now
i was working on 18 different [__]
therapies for me to get off coke the one
that really makes me laugh is
acupuncture
because when i first started going to
acupuncture i went after health
but then she turned me on to you know uh
my ankles were fat like i had a lot of
built up [__] in my ankles that's what
happens when you're a fat [__] your
ankles start to turn purple
it's not healthy you could [__] die
from that but anyway she started
circulation
ninety percent of
acupuncture is circulation it's you know
there's a blockage you're opening up
that blockage and the blood's gonna
treat it now and it washes it out nine
out of ten anyway it don't [__]
matter this is not acupuncture 101. my
point is that every tuesday i was very
honest with dr amy and i would tell her
dr amy put the acupuncture needle uh put
the needles in my ears
to help me with the addiction and she
would triple it up i would leave i would
take needles to go
like they actually have needles that
they put in you to go
and she would go let me put this needle
in your ear two of them to go and my job
every tuesday night was to snort a line
look in the mirror and make that [__]
needle pop out of my [__] ear did it
ever happen no
but i would snort coke i never looked in
the mirror but i would snort coke and
the [__] needles would pop out
throughout the night
that was my job
but after you do that for [__] once a
week
for a year
and eventually it's going to take it
happened with the acupuncture
it'll happen with the stand-up comedy
it'll happen whatever the [__] you want
if you if i listen i enjoy playing the
guitar but i play the guitar once a week
i don't even take lessons anymore if i
pick it up two times it's a party the
other night i picked it up like on a
wednesday night i was down here till
like 11 30. i was having a great time
but it's basically one thing i'm not
looking to be eric clapton or jeff beck
i'm not looking to make an album with
[__] uh
you know [__] uh crazy boy what's
they just [__] in his bed
yeah johnny depp is doing it hour with
jeff black
they're doing a yeah they're doing an
album of covers i can't wait for the i
told jimmy i can't wait for the first
hit to come up to me and go man did you
hear jeff beck and do and johnny are
doing them i can't wait for that album
to come on it's like god get your life
[__] together you're waiting for an
album of covers from johnny depp give me
a [__] break
what the [__] is wrong with people i
don't want to hear cover ever they got
to do a [__] cover album and but
those knuckleheads are around put on
eddie trunk this week on hair nation
you'll hear one of those how are you
doing this brad from
from [__] uh virginia
man did you hear that jeff blacklin and
johnny depp are putting an album out i
can't wait for that one shut the [__] up
check back's a hundred and johnny depp
who the [__] knows what's going on with
him all of a sudden he's [__] jim oh
paige and [__] i need that [__] like a
whole man
anyway guys little commitments
become big [__] commitments at any
level even when you're [__] 60 and
i'm living [__] proof just show up
once a week that's it
and then one week you'll go [__] it my
daughter's gonna watch some stupid
because her and my wife watch some
movies some night some nights i got [__]
to do down here but some nights i'm like
nah i'm taking the right to smoke a
[__] number or something that's what
i do i
get the [__] out of here now i can just
run up to new brunswick i think i'm
gonna do a
a set at my girl ally's room in
[__] asbury park
pretty soon she she had an opening on
june 30th
but if i'm doing the birth tour when i
come back i'm taking that week off but
anyway who gives a frenchman's [__] it's
monday [__] morning the 13th a
beautiful day to be alive and like i
preached on the joint i started on the
church every [__] week
our goal is to be better than the last
[__] week that's it just a
little bit more that's it i don't need
for you to lose to eight pounds just
lose an ounce
you're losing that even tell somebody i
lost eight ounces last week don't look
at you like what the [__] yeah i lost
eight ounces it's a start [__]
and all we're trying to do is just start
get get it going again [__] cove is
over that's it it's just a [__] it's
a sneeze and a fart and you move the
[__] on my daughter had it for two days
it disappeared in [__] four she was
sick for two days it's time to get on
with your life and it starts
[__] today on monday i'm ready
i'm psyched my balls are washed i'm
ready to dick slap a [__]
and that's it and that's that it's
monday the 13th
i'll be back wednesday the 15th
have a great [__] week we're starting
off with a great [__] podcast some
motivation and everything starts today
[__] that's it stay black and
now a word for my [__] sponsor
jack
all right i want to thank you
[__] for watching or listening
to the joint this week i had a good time
talking to your member
it all starts with [__] continuity
and nothing happens on the couch the
joint is brought to you by best spoke
post listen shake up your summer routine
with best spoke post and their new box
of awesome collections
listen i love the knife it's [__]
huge i'm dying to stab somebody whiskey
glasses and the one here they sent me a
[__] tremendous best smoke pose
partners with small businesses to bring
you the most unique
stuff every month i like that scotch box
with the hot sauces from all around the
country that's pretty nice you get some
wings
eat some [__] scorch box anyway take
the quiz at box of awesome.com and
they'll help you pick out the right box
for you you only pay a fraction of what
these boxes are worth
ninety percent of everything in the box
is from a small up-and-coming brand it's
a surprise box guys and it won't let you
down you have a great time opening it
you open it with your family like i said
i got a knife i got whiskey glasses and
a one hitter what i'm going to do is i'm
going to give you 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome
dot com again that's box of awesome dot
com and to code joey at checkout that's
box of awesome dot com code joey to get
20 off your first
box of awesome so go to box awesome dot
com code joey the joint is also brought
to you by blue choop boop listen if
you're looking to sling dick blue shoe
is gonna help you what does blue chew do
for you it helps you with your erectile
dysfunction whether it's light like
mines or it's heavy like mine or light
like a 28 year old you know when you're
28 you drink you got a little problem
but that ends today with blue chew i'm
gonna get you hooked up for the summer
sling dick with confidence never had
dead dick again her eyes are gonna be
like the inside of a [__] slap
machine they're gonna be spinning and
[__] when you get through with them blue
chew will help you sling dick the
process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com
talk to one of the licensed medical
providers once you're approved you'll
receive your prescription in days nobody
knows dick you understand me no doctor's
office no pharmacy the mailman walks
around [__] [__] anyway bluetooth
tablets are made in the usa it ships
right to your door to discreet package
and nobody could tell
so you could benefit from extra complex
i don't know is your dick a [__]
missile or does it look like a little
hard bark like mine you be the [__]
judge
if you could benefit blue chew has a
special deal for you
try blue chew for free use promo code
joey at checkout did you hear i said
free [__] suckers that's right free just
pay five dollars for shipping that's a
deal and a half you're going to be
[__] petting the hair on your dick
that's bluechew.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month free visit bluechew.com for
details and important safety information
i want to thank
boxer awesome and bluetooth for
sponsoring the joint i want to thank you
[__] for watching and listening
have a great week stay black and i'll be
back wednesday morning ready to sling
dick with my bluetooth
[Music]
you